hello everybody hope you are having a
fabulous day so far for those of you who
are in time zones west of me bright and
early morning to you good morning to
those in time zones all the way up to
Atlantic time zone where those and
Beyond good afternoon
or for those of you who are down under I
hope you're having a great evening so it
is time for ask doc live
uh we just want to thank everybody for
joining us here every single week as we
bring information to you that is
empowering
my name is Becca Dukes Kozak and I will
be your host for the next two hours as
we again bring empowering information to
you on what you can do as an individual
in your own life in your own community
that when you are working harder on
yourself and other Beauties other people
see it
they want to know what you're doing as
well and that's how we build communities
and especially healthier communities
and that's what our goal is today
because you know face it we look at the
news we look at those around us and we
every time we go to the store what are
we seeing we're seeing a hurting
Community hurting Nation a hurting world
when it comes to health
and we are here to provide solutions
to helping others find a better Journey
so without further ado
I hope you are all having a fabulous
fabulous fabulous day
if you are on live with us we will be
taking
questions for Dr Wallach so if you have
a question make sure that you go to that
Zoom menu
click on
raise hand
and that will raise your virtual hand
s and I call on people in the order that
their hands are raised so if you have a
question get your hand raised early if
you're able to come on camera with us
that would be absolutely fabulous
because Dr Wallach likes to see who he's
speaking with because you know the face
the coloring all of that tells such an
amazing story that will help him in
helping you find the best protocol for
you as well and we do we use nutrition
as our solution now what we put into our
mouth whether it's on a daily basis
whether it's our food whether it's our
drink
everything makes a difference within
ourselves but we have to be intentional
in what we do and don't put in our
bodies
I have to remind you that if you were
invited to this program by somebody
specific and it's not that I have to
remind you I get to remind you this is a
resource that we want others to share
and we want this to be a safe place that
if somebody is an associate with us they
know that they can take and share this
information and
have those that they share it with get
back with them because that's how we're
building our community is
allowing people to get information
from the man
from the good doctor without them having
to know everything and knowing that
those that they share it with will get
back with them because they have a
special way to order folks so if you
were again referred by somebody specific
get back with them thank them for the
information that you have heard today
and say I want to get started
so the content of this program is to
provide nutritional information only and
it is not intended to take the place of
your primary health care physician
and if you are nursing or pregnant or on
any type of pharmaceuticals we have to
requests that you consult with your
primary care physician before starting
any type of program even if it's eating
fruits and vegetables folks
so with that being said we
have the amazing opportunity to share
with you the man who has proven and
worked so hard to get us freedoms in
being able to do what we do as health
coaches as business owners within the
wellness field
and that's sharing information about
nutrition and how it really does affect
our bodies
and he's even proven he's one of the co
the founding fathers of a science called
epigenetics and epigenetics has proven
that the genetic theory that the way
that we transmit diseases the ones that
have been tagged and labeled as genetic
is false it's a lie folks
we have an R
empowered
so Dr Wallach
I am so excited to be able to host this
program with my co-host Ruth Ellen
Sanchez nasima Omar and Dr Judy here
today and jonty
it's just an honor Dr Wallach to be able
to share the information all of the
research that you spent decades
and doing yourself plus reviewing what
others have done
and either proving or disproving their
theories and findings so Dr Wallach
welcome to
ask doc live
well thank you so much for all the kind
words and background uh info Becca and
thank you to all the teammates and so
forth appreciates y'all
and of course our visitors and um it's
one of those things where we have lots
of work to do we have lots of
information but it needs to be engaged
in and put into our daily lives to be
able to get the benefit from it you know
just sort of knowing that it exists is
is a major part of it but then you have
to pull the trigger and make sure you're
you're employing it
um so I'm going to start out quickly
here with life expectancy because we're
going to show you how to increase that
significantly uh the USA our life
expectancy is 75.
the life expectancy of the Philippines
is 71. the life expectancy of Australia
82.9 New Zealand is 82.3 Japan is 84.7
Canada is 84. China is 76 the UK is 81
Russia is 72 South Africa
shootout freak okay it's 63.
um Mexico is 77 Italy is 83.
Egypt is 71 Sweden is 82.7 Germany is
81.26 Spain is 82. Ukraine is 71 and
Denmark is 77.2 now tons is 120. why are
they way out there for a much longer
life expectancy well we started
youngevity we spent a lot of time we
just didn't say okay we're going to open
up tomorrow we're going to grind up
um
um clay and
um we're you know grind up all these
rocks out of the ocean and so forth and
um uh we're gonna be like everybody else
we're just gonna be more aggressive you
know we want to be totally different so
we spent a good six months looking at
sources and nutrients and what makes
them different and so forth
instead of limestone okay
we looked at the uh hunzas with a life
expectancy of 120 what were they doing
well they're just Farmers uh in these
little villages in the mountains
um okay of in the himalayans and what
made him different was they were
surrounded by these volcanoes which are
constantly erupting showering their
water supply their lakes and ponds and
rivers and streams and their forests and
their Farm soils are okay with these
ashes which contained
um 75 or more minerals
okay and Limestone might only have three
or five
okay so this is why we chose to go the
direction we went in okay using the
hunza as our goal 120s instead of 75.
120 instead of 84.7 okay and so this is
where we started now we're going to kind
of zero in a little deeper here and look
at professional athletes let's look at
professional athletes not not colleges
what's worse for college let's just look
at professional athletes you think
they'd be getting the best of the best
um professional athletes the life
expectancy depending on the sport they
play in uh ranges from 53 to 59 we
average it out it's 56.7 okay
um you can see here the professional
athletes Senate age of 25
each year in America Alone 2 000 die
from sudden heart attack uh
hypertrophy current at the emergency is
actually the same cause of death as
suddenly death syndrome the deficiency
of a seal mineral
okay
and then uh let's see here we have
um billionaires billionaires their life
expectancy is 66.
um emergency room doctors their life
expectancy is 58.7 and so what's going
on here well that's because they believe
you can get everything you need just by
eating well that's not true
and so what we did uh was come up with a
set of three CDs and I called them
there's a new Bull in town named after
Red Bull there's a new Bull in town but
Red Bull only has one mineral on it they
brag about that they only had one
magnesium and I'm assuming that's
because a fashioned Red Bull after
um this guy the name of Bruce Lee who
was everybody's hero he was the fittest
guy in the world he was the best athlete
he was you know he was the guy
and he looked great he could function
but he died at 32 in 1973 he died at 32.
and they just it was 49 years ago and
they just released the doctor's view of
his cause of death was he drank too much
water well that's nonsense
so I I spent uh two half days
um a week ago on Saturday and Sunday
going through all his printed diets and
exercise programs and so forth to make a
long story short his breakfast was
um let's see here
um
cooked rolled oats okay
cooked rolled oats as a porridge okay
and then he would take a drink after
that he would take a smoothie on which
he would add a wheat germ to it which is
gluten and of course oats or gluten in
his
um cereal and then he would have
spaghetti for lunch and dinner gluten
gluten gluten again
and the only mineral that they were
talked about was magnesium I'm assuming
he had some muscle cramps and he was
taking magnesium to help relieve the
muscle cramps
well here's a guy who thought that
looking buff because he didn't want
meeting any animal fat although he did
eat beef but he had very lean beef
there's nothing wrong with beef but he
was missing all these nutrients okay he
was missing all these nutrients because
he was eating gluten gluten gluten
gluten with every meal and every snack
okay and so he died of chronic
complications of gluten consumption and
I'm going to have I'm you know trying to
get the autopsy slides of those tissues
and all the biochemistry and all that
kind of stuff to prove it but just his
diet is enough to tell you he screwed up
badly okay so
um
one of these three CDs the first one is
dead athletes don't lie
um that one we looked at
um
professional athletes and University
athletes and Olympic athletes we find
that they're dying in their 30s and 40s
and 50s and so forth and so what what's
going on there
they're all nutritionally deficient and
then that's CD number two exercise on
cementation of suicide and this included
people who own big corporations uh very
famous
people who were in the governments and
so forth and Professionals of all kinds
and they they died in their 30s 40s and
50s and so we have those in exercising
suicide in the third CD in the set was
what kills billionaires billionaires can
afford the best medicine the best food
the best of everything and yet their
life expectancy is 66. this is crazy
when you think about it but they were
given misinformation by the medical
assistant oh eat well you get everything
you need don't waste your money on
taking vitamins and minerals you can get
everything you need just by eating well
uh oh you have a geneticism on immune
disease well as Becca pointed out I was
able to find out that there are no
genetically transmitted diseases
there are no autoimmune diseases but
okay we do have a problem and of course
the U.S Senate recognized this in 1936
it came out with U.S Senate document 264
1936 and said
our farm stalls in the United States no
longer contain sufficient minerals to
support the healthy life and longevity
in humans those views in a document of
264 1936 why is that because at three
o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September
um Boris
um 1882
and Thomas Edison pulled a switch in the
first commercial electric generating
plant
and within 18 years
um we had been without
wood stoves from bar places we went to
electricity how many wood ashes are left
over
um when you have electricity none
when you're using hydroelectric
how many minerals get through there to
re-refurbish the Pharmaceuticals Every
Spring like in history maybe it's
Lottery spring when we stop the floods
and everybody was happy oh no we don't
have any floods anymore plus electricity
what a great life well it was
all wrong okay
remember
that um there's a new Bull in town Red
Bull 1987 from Austria monster 1985 two
years earlier with the Coca-Cola product
Rockstar 2001 Pepsi Cola young Duty 2011
rebound and
um it's one of those things where
um let's see here I'll just give you a
short version the rebound has 75
minerals and Tesla took us six months to
get started because we wanted to find
another place where the Mills were
coming from that the hunzas were getting
and so we have five locations we get
these metals from
um
plantar metal 75 minerals and
um rebound
you know 75 mils Red Bull has won
Rockstar has won
uh that's enough I can go into the rest
of the Furnace but the best nutritional
program of course is rebound we have the
sticks
okay take with me
um when we're traveling okay here we are
there's Barry here okay the sticks okay
you take the sticks that way I can put
them into a bottle of water when I'm on
the road I take these in my suitcase and
I travel on an airplane because when
they're inspecting you you put the
[Music]
um
okay
we put the the cancer in there it's a
powder the guy is inspecting it for
safety they never put the top one tight
again so your whole suitcase is going to
be covered with the powder so I take the
sticks and then of course I also like
the cans but it does have carbonation so
what I do is I pop the tops okay
um say two of them before bedtime at
night put in the refrigerator so Marnie
and all the bubbly is gone they're flat
and I'll have one with breakfast and one
with lunch or maybe maybe two hours
after lunch okay don't take the rebound
of any form after
five or six o'clock unless you're gonna
stay up all night dancing or something
like that
and
you get 100 nutrients 75 minerals and 25
vitamins amino acids to maintain your
body and to repair your body
every cell every system every organ
requires these things don't forget
eggs you need eggs 25 of your brain
weight your spinal cord weight is
cholesterol when you look at the whole
body burden of cholesterol the
cholesterol in your brain is spinal cord
make up 75 percent of the cholesterol
your total body burden and cholesterol
okay
and so
um Alzheimer's disease costs us 305
billion dollars a year to distribute the
symptoms that's the USA only
and let's see here arthritis in the
America alone again we only spend 626.8
billion
and uh Diabetes Type 2 we spent 342
billion a year in America heart disease
316.8 billion obesity 260 billion uh
high blood pressure 131 billion multiple
sclerosis 85 billion uh asthma and kids
under the age of 10 80 billion dollars a
year holy moly and then Kenya Alice is
24 billion I'm pointing that out because
all of those are preventable reversible
and you can end them in weeks by taking
the right nutrition and staying away
from the bad foods and Max lines and
absorption and stop
um on the inflammation this is not
difficult
but you do have to be proactive now you
do this for your car
you go into the quilling station you're
putting gas in your car you're checking
the air in your tire you're checking
your oil you're not just going to put
dirt from Texas in your car well come on
there's bound to be some oil on that
that's dirt from Texas well I don't want
to put oil in there and I can put dirt
from Texas and sell you a little money
well your car is going to burn up you
put dirt from Texas in your engine
instead of oil
so people treat their car better than
they treat themselves this is crazy okay
and so it's one of those things where
let's let's get our stuff together here
now
let's look at archives of course we have
the healthy Bone and Joint pack for
arthritis uh we have 332 million 228 200
people okay in America okay and we have
58.5 million cases of doctor diagnose
arthritis anastasis probably three times
that many they're not diagnosed by
doctors people who say oh I got
arthritis because they have pain in
their joints they want to go to a doctor
for that
and then a juvenile I was trying it's
under age 16 we have 300 000 in the USA
300 000 a third of a million kids in the
United States with arthritis okay and
osteoporosis remember for arthritis or
spending 626.8 billion dollars a year to
treat the symptoms osteoporosis we're
spending 2.3 trillion
2.3 trillion United States alone when
you take the U.S Canada and the European
Union together we spend 6.5 trillion
dollars each year just to treat the
symptoms of osteoposis not to prevent it
or cure it okay
um when you get osteoporosis of the
skull and of course this uh all this
stuff is in the book in the CD it's all
in your head
uh this is just flying off the shelf
because doctors have no idea doctors
have no idea about the um osteoporosis
in the cell and then and the um from the
rest of the body
what I got the book up oh you got the
book up okay great thank you and and
then
um there's there's 37 different diseases
you can get from Ashley posted to the
skull alone 37 different diseases and we
we name them in the book in the CD sets
and obviously you have to take the 90
essential nutrients and that's why we
came out with the health abandoned heart
attack with 215 nutrients the core 90 is
still in there okay but when you have
osteoporosis it's going you lose your
sense of smell uh you get optic nerve
atrophy you slowly lose your vision your
pupil will not respond in light the
cytosis double vision
um you have trigenal neuralgia cranial
nerve number five being squeezed pain uh
cranial nerve number six double vision
um crayon room number seven Bell's Palsy
or face troops
and um then you see here tonight it's
raining in the Years deafness vertigo
dizziness cranial nerve number eight
launch of the gag reflex your voice
changes this is kind of a new disease in
town doctors don't know what this is
um there's a famous singer from Canada
okay who's just diagnosed with all these
problems and one of her problems was she
has trouble with her throat and her
singing her voice so she had to cancel
her stuff you know we're talking about
clean
um
okay Celine Dion right and so she's she
had to cancel her whole stuff so we're
hoping that somebody will contact her uh
we're waiting our hands in in front of
her her team's face because we can we
can heal her we can get her back on the
road we actually have worked with
entertainers who are singers and and so
forth and actors and actresses and they
were in the same position she is and
just after 70 days two and a half months
or ninety percent better okay and so
this is something that Celine Dion needs
to contact us or her team because we can
get her back on the road again as they
say okay and then uh let's see here
tonight is ringing the ears as again
cranial nerve number eight belongs to
the gag reflexes and voice changes and
taste that is Scrambler number nine
yes your priest is terrible pain in the
stomach I mean it'll drop your knees and
like oh you got an ulcer but then then
you also get hiccups you get afib and
doctors think and afib atrial
fibrillation your heart beats it
regularly think it's a heart problem
they want to anesthetize you cut you
open take your heart out touch it with a
branding iron to try and find the spot
that's causing The Irregular Heartbeat
it's really the skull squeezing the
tense cranial nerve okay easily repaired
very quickly we do that all the time
loss of the trapezius muscle ability to
raise your your arms above your head as
cranial nerve number 11 criminal nerve
number 12.
atrophy the tongue of speech and ability
to communicate so if you're getting
cranial nerve number nine and child
being sweet you cannot communicate okay
and then of course the spinal cord being
squeezed it comes out of the back of the
skull it's called wallix
um fibrosis because when the skull is
squeezing that spinal cord there's 17
different diseases that occur south of
the skull including getting up every
hour at night to urinate
um we're talking about many many things
uh you know uh going on everything from
your sex life to your regular heartbeat
we're talking about dizziness balance
um
you name it they'll amputate your leg
the doctors want to give you a double
knee replacement double hip replacement
and all you have to do is get rid of all
the bad foods maximize your absorption
take their your 215 nutrients and
healthy brain and heart pack
um and go ahead and take your synaptic
h3h5 today to rebuild the the myelin
which is the white man of the brain
which is the cholesterol in the brain
and it all goes away this is not
difficult we've been doing this for a
long time and so I'm going to turn this
over to Becca here we've got just a few
minutes here in this part of the segment
and you've seen these things back but
you have seen these things have you not
okay you're shaking your head
I have seen them many many times Dr
Wallach and
you know it's
it's 70 days
90 days
I have one recording artist that was
having some issues we put them on the
protocol Dr Wallach and on my follow-up
at two weeks he's like Becca I think I'm
at least 70 percent better and that was
over a month ago and now
um talking to him he's like I'm at 90
percent
he's like I I believe in this so much
that that's going to be in my upcoming
music videos so I am super excited to be
able to share more and more of the
youngevity products
um in a much bigger way Dr Wallach
because with all of the research that
you've put into it with all of the you
know formula
okay anal formulasm okay we're going to
use anal formulism because you don't
skimp on anything your son Steve if
something is not available that product
does not get created and does not get
distributed
until all of the ingredients that meet
are specifications are available to be
put into the formula there is no
skimping there is no substituting for
something that's inferior
and the fact that we are going to be
able to get this on a much bigger
platform Dr Wallach is well deserved
well deserved so if anybody that here is
hearing what we are saying today
knows of anybody that is struggling
make sure that you share this program
with them you can go to askdoclive.com
you're going to find all of the replays
for all of our programs since we started
in July of 2020
and be able to share information with
them on our website at stocklive.com you
can even do a search for specific types
of conditions we try to stay away from
medical terms
um because of the way censorship is but
put in symptoms
and you will probably find at least
half a dozen or more
um videos that we have done in the past
that share about that condition and what
you can do or help others
so that they can
have a better health Journey because
Dr Wallach with all of the numbers that
you mentioned
and the average ages and
then looking at the amount of money that
we hear in the United States spend
on sick care
we're towards the bottom Dr Wallach of
life expectancy of longevity that's
correct and we're spending more money
for health care than all the other
industrialized nations will combined
we're supposed to have the greatest
Health Care system in the world just ask
any doctor that will tell you they'll
Brad beat their chest like Tarzan and
say yes we have the best health services
in the world but then when you look at
the statistics
we ranked 57s
okay I have over 100 different
um industrialized nations uh we rank
57th or in some cases 54th and it's one
of those things where
um it's it's a which they say it's a
false
um
um it's it's also wired to we're getting
we're giving ourselves a false award
here
yeah and I think there's false security
and thinking we have the greatest
medical system in the world
yet when you look at the other numbers
if we have the greatest system in the
world
why are we what'd you say 54. 54th
of all the countries
when it comes to life expectancy
that is crazy and then I don't know what
number we are as far as dollars spent
but we're at the top of the list we
spend more than all of them combined
almost
oh almost because I've seen some charts
where we are so far above everybody else
on the amount of money that is spent
to manage health
and it's sick care
I I was I have to share this I was
really tickled so I was getting our
chewable vitamin C's because one they
taste so great after a while like and
two I just wanted to get some extra
vitamin C and they there's some other
additives in there that just help boost
the immune system
and as I was looking at it it said the
recommended dose for heel care
and I don't know if that's a typo
or what but it brought a smile to my
face because that's exactly what it is
it's heel care
and so I just had to share that that's
something I saw this morning but Dr
Wallach
you know we
bring this program to people each and
every week
because we believe
that people deserve it
yeah absolutely
all human beings are
and and that's why I have my co-hosts
that continually show up to share
information in the chat so if you're
here live with us make sure that you
have that chat featured open
because nasima and Ruth Ellen are
just loading that chat with information
that provides you with how to get
more in touch with the resources that we
will be speaking of today and Dr Wallach
you did not mention and I was really
surprised
and maybe I just didn't hear it
Dr Wallach
has his own website because he doesn't
make any money off of the products that
are sold through youngevity he has
detached himself from youngevity the
company
because he doesn't want anybody saying
well you're just promoting these
products because you make money off of
them no he makes his money off of his
books
and you can find all of his books at
drjwalik.com
d-r-j w a l l a c h.com
and you'll find all of his Publications
all of his Publications including our
bundles that are going to be coming out
we have bundles that are going to be
released here shortly that are going to
provide some savings whether you're one
of our health coaches whether you're
just a health Enthusiast or you're in it
for the long haul you want to dig deep
we're going to have bundles that are
available for you as well with some
significant savings and
for those of you who have your own
podcast your own websites your own
blog
we're also going to be having an
affiliate program
for drj Wallach so that as you share Dr
wallach's books with others he's going
to give you a thank you check for
sharing so I think that is absolutely
fabulous because Dr Wallach this
information needs to be shared there's
yeah just looking at the United States
numbers alone
it breaks my heart
now they're really sad with all the
money we spend for health care that
we're so low
um and all these other countries outlive
us they're healthier than us and we're
spending
so much more money than they are and
um you know you've already said it the
it's the the medical system that's
reaping reaping the um
Financial Rewards
oh yeah
um huge financial rewards and yeah
they've got expensive equipment folks
but
that expensive equipment is killing
offsells rather than building them up
and nourishing them and yeah
this is a good point to throw in again
uh it was Sir
um Celine Dion
right okay
um the doctors told her that she had an
autoimmune disease
and her body's attacking has her brain
is our immune disease and
um they call it SPS
okay
SPS which is
um stiff person syndrome stiff person
syndrome and autoimmune disease of human
beings
uh that that falls into the science of
crapola
yeah
I mean you you support the body as a
whole you support connective tissue
reduce inflammation through your diet
and supplementation
and it's amazing how stuff just
disappears
we always say give us 90 days
here's 90 days you're going to see
something positive in 90 days and
um if you don't that means you're still
being naughty like
um let's see here
um Bruce Lee he was naughty he was
eating gluten
um for breakfast he was eating gluten
for snacks he was eating gluten for
lunch and dinner he's eating gluten for
nighttime snacks he had cakes and pies
which is not bad
but it was bad because the crust were
all gluten crust
and you know that he had all flour in
the cake and everything a wheat flour
and of course in his smoothies he would
put the wheat wheat germ in there uh
which is a gluten and
uh he ate spaghetti for lunch and dinner
and so on and that's why he died at 32.
and it's one of those things where
to take 40 and nine years and wait 49
years he they probably waited until all
his close relatives were dead and then
they said oh he died because he drank
too much water
I mean how can they get away with that
how can they get away with saying such a
thing on such a
which I say he he was held up was one of
the greatest
Fitness gurus in America
maybe the world
and he dies at 32 because he ate badly
so
it's amazing Dr Wallach
but I mean if I can see if he was
took and drank a full gallon of water
you know that didn't have any type of
minerals in it and it depleted his
potassium and I I have heard and seen
you know that
you know not have good effects but
gluten all his life he can't absorb
potassium even if he took it
that's very true
it's very true
well Dr Wallach I have so many questions
that come into me through the critical
Health newsletter that I'd like to be
able to touch on some of these and get
some answers okay okay let's go for it
um so the first one is coming from Dale
and unfortunately Dell didn't give his
age or weight but he says my doctor has
advised me my blood platelet count is
slightly low
please advise me on steps I can take to
bring it up to a satisfactory level
which he doesn't give an actual level
but I know in general what you're going
to recommend
and should I be anxious about this I
would greatly appreciate your opinion
yeah well platelets are required of
course to clutch your blood if you get a
cut or something like that and so they
are
um required for safety for your life
okay to get in any kind of trauma uh or
for some reason another have a rupture
but artery because you're deficient
other minerals and you don't have any
artery healthy arteries rupture if you
don't have those platelets you're gonna
bleed to death okay so platelets are
important and they're actually made in
your bone marrow your bone marrow is one
of your best friend when it comes to
your blood and your immune system
your bone marrow makes red blood cells
makes white blood cells makes platelets
makes antibodies makes all kinds of
stuff so you gotta do that well let's go
since he didn't give us a weight let's
just go by 100 pounds
gotta get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no wheat nobody Ryan oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbon or drinking
the diet one's got to go and I wanted to
have three eggs twice a day per 100
pounds evaluate three eggs twice a day
per hundred pounds of body weight they
have to be soft boiled soft poached soft
scramble and butter they cannot be hard
boiled and they cannot be fried
then I want him to have per 100 pounds
of body weight one healthy brain and
heart pack a month
um half of those twice a day per 100
pounds by the way if he weighs 150
pounds of 200 pounds he needs two health
degree in hard packs to take a full Rose
fight today okay so you know how the
system works
and then he also needs the MSM I want
him per 100 pounds of body weight to get
one bottle a month so it take three
twice a day for 100 pounds of body
weight 150 pounds you need three three
times a day again we're building the
bone marrow so he can get his completely
count up but I guarantee you if he has
low platelets he's got other issues that
are going on that can cost him his life
and so he needs to jump on this and then
he needs the Beyond Osteo FX The Scuba
that with his morning drinks with his
evening drink he needs the collagen
peptides a scuba that was his morning
drinks with an evening drink he collagen
peptides for collagen and cartilage
um from fish poultry beef and sheep and
they will help rebuild the bone marrow
most people never get to see their bone
marrow
their whole life yet it's so important
to her immune system into the
circulatory system and the respiratory
system okay
[Music]
uh in their vascular system and yet most
people never get to see their bone
marrow and then now let's see here
uh what else I'm sure I'm missing
something
what did I miss Becca oh vitamin D3 He
needs vitamin D3 three of those twice a
day per 100 pounds of body weight and um
they they will help him absorb these
minerals and put them in the right place
so the bone we're all going to do its
job
because that's the place to start and
don't forget a rebound for energy
um it has 100 nutrients in our rebound
storage shrink has 100 nutrients in it
75 minutes and 25 vitamins amino acids
Red Bull has one mineral magnesium
okay and
um the rest is you know sugar and
caffeine and and that kind of stuff okay
so you really really want to go with our
rebound
Dr Wallach if he's not absorbing I would
definitely recommend the ultimate
enzymes okay to help break through and
add extra absorption
um breaking the foods down
so that those nutrients are bioavailable
and also breaking through that gluten
coding that's in the digestive system so
that you get better absorption also
yeah if you've never done it to
everybody out there you can go to Siri
and ask Siri to show you a comparison
between a normal intestinal lining small
intestinal lining and one that's damaged
by gluten and I know you have a great
three series picture Becca of a gluten
damage in people's intestines I don't
know if you have access to it now
okay so she's looking to see if she can
get it up there on the screen but your
your intentional lining should look like
a shag rug should have all these little
eyes sticking up like a Shad rug and
then when you eat gluten all those
villains go away because the gluten is
so caustic it kills your Villi and now
your intestines look like a plastic tube
you lose 90 percent of your absorptive
surface when you eat gluten and that's
what killed Bruce Lee at age 32 get
gluten with every meal he had gluten at
every dessert and um uh you know he he
drank some beer and wine nothing wrong
with that but I'm sure he was drinking
beer that's made from oh wheat okay and
so it's one of those things where
um he was killed for lack of knowledge
he died from lack of knowledge and he
was going uh with a very simplistic idea
of just you know uh just eat all these
sort of Basic Foods
along with cultures like the Italians
you know eat spaghetti twice a day I
have rolled oats uncooked rolled oats
for breakfast
um and put wheat germ in my smoothies uh
it's you know how crazy can you get okay
and so
um but everybody looked up to him
because when you looked at him I mean he
was he was ripped I mean this guy was a
picture of what everybody wanted to be
as a male you know looking and being
ripped and just every muscle is showing
um no fat not one Grandma fat in his
body and he could you know jump up in
the air and kick somebody in the head
and all this kind of stuff in the movies
and the TV and everything and so he was
the guy but he died at 32 because he did
it wrong
he did it wrong it cost him his life and
I'm sure it was a shock to so many of
his followers but then they never could
well we don't know
um and then they said well you know he
just didn't have good genes for
longevity and then 49 years later they
come out and finally I think all his
close relatives died
um and so nobody would go after them and
so they said oh he died of drinking too
much water
how silly can you get
well that's that's very silly Dr Wallach
and there's a lot of things that could
be the reason why that they have waited
49 years
um to be able to or just
to make this report and then you know Dr
Wallach as you've said you want to see
the slides you want to see what they
actually saw and what took so long and
I I hate to think
they may not know what they're looking
at because again metal doctors don't get
training
in in nutritional deficiencies
okay
they think lupus is on immune disease
they think rheumatoid arthritis is in
our immune disease okay
um they think these things are honoring
me in
uh no no no no no
well and I can't believe that the good
Lord would provide a body and create a
body that would a quote unquote attack
itself
so giving the body what it needs what it
was designed with which you know think
about it and the dust of the earth
what's in the dust of the earth
depending on where it's fat and in the
beginning they weren't deplete
um that's what we need to continually
and intentionally give our bodies each
and every day
now unfortunately I'm gonna have to talk
with my technical Guru because it's not
given me the option to share this Dr
Wallach and it's given the option to
share almost everything but my screen so
we're gonna get that
um up and we'll make sure that it's also
available for those of you who follow
askdoc live and are on Facebook we'll
put that in the askdoc live Facebook
page we'll put it on the Dead Doctors
Don't Lie Facebook page as well so that
we can make sure that everybody can see
the difference between healthy villi
modest damage of the Villi and also
severe damage of the billi it's it's
like you say Dr Wallach you've got the
shag rug you know with all the different
surfaces
all that surface
that allows absorption and then whenever
it starts to get damaged it clumps
together and then gets really hard and
Compact and that's where you get leaky
gut
you get that hardness things start to
crack the things that aren't supposed to
be into the body and blood start leaking
through because it doesn't have that
protective healthy barrier that only
absorbs the nutrients that the body
needs
so
let's go to another question Dr Wallach
and again folks if you're on live with
us go ahead and raise your hand if you
have questions I know we had a hand up
just a little bit ago but I saw that the
hand went down so I don't know if
and one thing that I love about
um technology is it's fabulous when it
works right absolutely fabulous
so
next question Dr Wallach
has to do with
is it glioblastoma
G
um l i o the big Leo Leo blastoma
so
Drew is writing into me and his
sister-in-law has been diagnosed with
this on Monday
she's five foot five
175 pounds
49 years old
she
has no blood pressure issues no blood
sugar issues
no skin issues but she does have Lupus
and it even specifically says there's no
skin rash but she does have lupus
um and they are looking at doing six
weeks of radiation and an oral chemo
peel
um
well the first thing I would do before
you go any farther Becca is give us 90
days before she goes for radiation okay
a glial cells are part of the brain okay
they're part of the communicating part
of the brain Leo glial cells
and so lupus
um has to do with irritable bowel
syndrome
muscle weakness
sometimes skin problems usually on the
face and upper body okay but if you're
eating buckwheat you're going to have
that that rash on your face in your
chest but if you're not eating Buck we
have everything else but you don't get
the rash the rash is produced by
buckwheat
okay so back in the old days you know
people everybody doesn't get lupus but
those who are eating buckwheat
we got lupus
okay so what would you recommend for her
Dr Wallach as far as giving us 90 days I
know it's going to be the healthy body
brain and heart pack to start well she
needs two of them per month because
she's 175 pounds give her all the bad
foods and then she needs three eggs
twice a day with soft yolks softball
soft poached soft sauce scrambling
butter
not hard boiled not fried then I want
her to have
two dollars a month of the MSM so you
can take three of breakfast sweet
luncheon dinner time
um she needs to take um uh let's see
here the uh or say the msmg see uh two
of the canisters of the collagen
peptides as you can take a scuba that
with her morning drink it's where
they're eating drink that's gonna help
rebuild cartilage and ligaments and
tendons and connective tissue including
in the brain and the skull and all that
kind of stuff
in the skin and let's see here and the
intestines and so on but she's got to
get rid of that glutines you've got to
get rid of all that stuff
um and uh let's see here
uh it wouldn't hurt for her to get a
hair analysis to show her that she's not
been absorbing nutrition because when
you have something like lupus your
intestines again they don't look like a
shag rug anymore they just look like
just a plastic tube and so you can't
efficiently absorb stuff even if you're
taking it as a settlement I took those
supplements for six oh there you go
there you go yeah
thank you thank you I don't know why I
as host was not able to do that but
thank you for sharing this and and
excuse me for interrupting you Dr
Wallach but there you go you got the
healthy Villi the modest damage and the
severe damage
so yeah okay so for for Drew's
sister-in-law we've got the two brain
and heart packs three eggs twice a day
dmsm two bottles so she could take three
three times a day the collagen peptides
two canisters so she can take two
Scoops a day
please continue
okay and then she needs the synaptive
through those twice a day so two miles a
month so she can let the brain cells
talk to each other and go right there
and she needs to have the uh let's see
here I'd ever get the memory FX take
three of those times today uh she also
needs the
um
ultimate daily classic tablets as you
get through those twice a day so she can
get the circulation into the brain and
the heart and the kidneys and the
intestines and the skin and every place
else and
um don't do radiations do not do
radiation for nutritional deficiency
that that's kind of like Bruce Lee don't
go there
okay so Dr Wallach I do have a question
for you and this is a question that
comes up to me very often I know that
Drew is in Canada an ultimate daily
classic their government will not cross
the border is there something that we
can add in there other than ultimate
daily classic that would help to promote
the circulation and
clean the blood The Bistro's capsule so
you can take the details capsules
twice a day three these stress capitals
twice a day
and um
that's where that's where I would go
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach
and you know what we're close to uh top
of the hour
and we can take one more question or we
could take a break Dr Wally let's take
one more question before the break
okay
so
Jeff was on with us a couple weeks ago
he's 52 years old
he's six foot five
weighs
238 pounds
now his major condition is well first
he's on number 16 as far as Specialists
to try to figure out what's wrong with
him
he says basically I'm very healthy
but
I have never smoked anything ever and
suddenly developed a breathing issue
where I'm not able to get a full breath
lying on my back
when I walk
um at more more than a leisurely Pace my
inhale is not linear linear but choppy
and when I'm submerged in my pool I
literally can only take baby inhales
um so he did admit that he wasn't able
to write everything down so we're going
to make sure that we get him the
protocol in an email
um so that he can get started on the
program so what's getting started
quickly here I believe he's got
osteoporosis of the skull uh squeezing
the 12th cranial nerve
okay which specifically goes after the
respiratory system
okay and also uh everything south of the
skull down the spinal cord okay so he's
a perfect example of that the 12 cream
Urban squeeze
and um did we he said he's 52 years old
and of course osteoporosis is a skull is
not really related to age babies are
born with osteoposis of the skull okay
um
and so it's one of those things where I
think that's his problem when you get 60
Specialists can't figure it out that
means it's something very simple okay
because definitely they want to find a
fracture they want to find a bullet and
they want to find a Cancer and they
can't find that stuff they just throw up
their hands and say oh you have an
autoimmune disease that's how that sort
of scenario comes around but I believe
the generosity approaches the
statistical if we were to ask him my
questions would be how many times a
night does he wake up to to urinate once
a couple of days ago I had one guy he
said he wakes up 20 times a night
urinate he's your name were you on that
one did you hear that one yeah he's
urinating like every half hour at night
doctors couldn't figure out what his
problem was because he announced he
approached to the skull squeezing the
spinal cord the spinal cord is telling
the you're glad to urinate that's what's
going on here okay so that's what's
going on here for this guy and of course
also the respiratory stuff
uh is involved here uh when you when you
squeeze the spinal cord uh you can get
COPD chronic absorb the pony disease you
get hiccups you get afib atrial
fibrillation Foundation a lot of
questions we need to ask this guy
and I'm sure the 60 Specialists or how
many of it was I can't figure it out
because they don't take into
consideration
osteoporosis of skull squeezing any one
or more of the 12 pairs of cranial
energy on the spinal cord and so this is
what this guy is suffering from so the
238 pounds when we get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no glutens no wheat nobody
around oats no buckwheat no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the dot ones got
to go and then he needs two healthy
brain and heart packs a month to follow
something twice a day he needs two
bottles a month at the end of stem so we
take three at breakfast sweet lunch at
dinner time he needs two canisters a
month of the intelligent diet so you
take a scuba that was breakfast drinks
through the evening drink
and also getting the synaptic take three
of those twice a day
um and also uh let's see here uh have
them take the
um ultimate daily classic Taylor three I
I get three bottles so you can take
three at breakfast right lunch at dinner
time okay and you say is this guy in
Canada
no this one's not in Canada this one's
here in the states okay so he can get
the ultimate daily classic talents and
um that's going to help him with with
blood flow in the brain the heart
coronary arteries kidneys all that kind
of stuff
Oliver's Body his lungs and so um he's
going to see a miraculous results here
he's got to do the whole thing he can't
cherry pick and they're not they're
always asking which nutrient is it
because they just want to buy iron only
okay or something like that and that's
sort of the mentality that doctors are
placing their head well you need some
iron oh no you need 90 essential
nutrients you need more than just iron
okay and so
um let's go with that and uh have him
call us every week or every two weeks
every 10 days whatever he needs to call
us
so that we're able to follow him and
guide him and kind of steer him in the
right direction because he's going to
very quickly see some benefit if he
follows what we're suggesting for him
okay with that you can see here we're at
that up and down time okay
let's take a little break Dr Wallach can
everybody get up and stretch let's get
that fluid rolling I'm going to go ahead
and remove Doc's Spotlight and
foreign
everybody that you're watching ask.com
so this program is brought to you by
askdoclive.com we are a website that
provides information including the
replays of all of our programs and we
have a store that goes through
it gives information about the products
that we're offering
but if you are invited to this program
by somebody specific get back with them
they probably have their own special way
of ordering and we want to make sure
that they get credit for referring you
to our program we will be right back
after this short break
all right I am back Dr Wallach will be
back here shortly as well as our
co-hosts and while we're waiting for
them
I just I can't say
you know how honored I am to be able to
provide this program to you
um as a certified holistic health coach
and also the
student services administrator
I love seeing so many of our coaches on
our calls and inviting their guests and
sharing this information with them
because as a health coach you do not
have to have all of the answers
knowing your resources and where to find
answers is the important part and that
is what the Institute of holistic health
does in helping you learn about the four
areas of Health
how they're affected by disease and we
go deeper into Dr wallach's research and
what he has done in order to not just
find but prove that his research is in
fact legitimate for the many of you that
don't know Dr Wallach used to have his
own clinics he had more than one where
he was using his formulas and he these
clinics were not the vet clinics okay
this is after that veterinarian stage
where after he went back to school and
became a naturopathic physician he
opened clinics because he wanted to heal
people
people would come and these were not
just like not all of them were walk-in
clinics where you had a 15-20 minute
appointment walked out with a whole bag
full of supplements some of these were
actually Healing Centers where you would
come and stay a couple days and then
Spas where you got full treatment and I
would love to open up a few more of
those and bring them back when the time
is right
but he took his findings and the
formulas that were created and
implemented them in his patients
and had results when they followed the
eating plan when they took the
supplementation
they got better
and I love his little saying how he
treats people like dogs but they do get
better
well he's actually a very kind soul and
sometimes we don't always see that
whenever he is speaking with others
because we want to make sure that we're
listening
we're listening and I know he talks fast
he does
but that's why we have these replays
available
so go to apps.live.com and you can find
the replays of all of our programs and
listen to them again
and if you're while you're listening if
you think of somebody oh well they have
that symptom or that condition
I wonder if this would help them
share this program with them let them
have the opportunity to hear that there
are alternatives
that they can Implement in their own
life and be an empowered individual
so as we're waiting for Dr Wallach to
get back here with us
um
we have people with their hands up and I
love to be able to get to them first we
have some questions in the comments that
I'm going to be getting to as well in
the chat so
you know as they're going through and
providing all this information in the
chat and people are commenting
I just so appreciate my co-hosts because
they make sure that I try not to miss
anybody with their questions so I do
have a couple questions in the chat here
that I'm going to be going back to
um in this next segment of ask doc live
so
I'm waiting for Dr Wallach I know he's
gonna be here soon
hey there I'm gonna turn my camera off
so that this will show on the audio uh
the reply
yes please do
please do please do so she figured out
and in it for me it's backwards but hey
I think we can all figure it out okay
let me fix it let me fix it
damaged Villi from gluten intolerance
all right
is that better
there's different severities not yet
there's different severities of damage
that happens within the intestines
healthy villi
even with that healthy Villi then we
don't know the age of the individual
that's better thank you
um
as you look
and you follow
the different fingers that are coming up
and down up and down that's all surface
that as the food is moving through the
digestive system as it's being broken
down that's opportunity that those
nutrients are being absorbed into the
body and getting into the cells that
are re require the nutrients
and then as that surface
becomes less and less
then you're getting less absorption and
that is hi Dr Wallach
yeah the only people who are not
sensitive gluten are dead people
there you go
I didn't think that I was sensitive to
gluten Dr Wallach but I'll tell you what
after completely removing it from my
diet
it's amazing how much better I feel and
I thought I was feeling really good 25
years younger than you thought you were
there there you go
25 years younger yes so I look forward
forward to getting old
um
because I don't feel old
where at 20 I did feel old
not anymore I love it
but Dr Wallach let's get to some of the
questions that we had in the
um
let's go to one so Liz let me pull it
back up my screen keeps going away
actually as I pull that up let's go to
the next tan that's up Dr Wallach and
that is David David go ahead and unmute
yourself thanks for having your camera
on and you are live with Dr Wallach hi
Dr Wallach
hello
um I've recently started on the
youngevity products for my arthritis
um I'm on the healthy body style pad
they're gluco gel and shortly I'll be on
the MSM
but my question is for something that
happened eight years ago
um I had a badly compressed spinal cord
and they did triple fusion surgery on me
and about a month after that surgery I
got up to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the night and I collapsed on
the floor badly spasming in my back and
had to be rushed to the hospital I want
to interrupt you here let me know what
you're here you say you had surgery
where where was this compression of your
spine was it in the middle of your back
your low back or by your neck and your
skull
yeah okay
um and the odds are we have in addition
to having stuff going on in your
vertebrae in your disc and all that kind
of stuff you also have stuff going on in
your skull
the only tinnitus are ringing in your
ears no okay honey we know you have
balance problems
um how many times you wake up at night
to urinate once three times five times
two maybe three two three yeah you know
how she approaches to the skull
squeezing the spinal cord that's they're
two they're working too low you got to
go up to your skull okay because this is
where the real problem is at and they're
doing the typical doctor stuff by you
know doing uh treating you like a young
athlete and working on your disc and
working on your vertebrae and stuff like
that you got to go higher
um and so
um there have any other stuff going on
has your voice changed any has your
voice got in the past year
um no but ever since then I have a mass
in my lower left back it feels like
there's a yoga Block in there like it
feels that big and it's never gone away
in eight years and I was just curious
it's something they can feel or you do
you feel it only
they can't see anything but you feel
something right it's like a big like a
massive dead flesh it feels like okay
you have
um as you approaches to the skull
Okay so
you're heading the right direction but
you need to get rid of all the bad foods
everybody in your household dog cat bird
fish spouse Brothers kids renters
everybody you got to be gluten-free you
know we burn our oats no fried foods no
processed Meats
um absolutely no
um
uh let's see here oh uh we've got to get
rid of shed the gluten and you got to
um get rid of the uh
wheat bread around oats and buckwheats
or did you read buckwheat
no I've made those changes already to my
diet my wife hasn't no but when you were
younger did you eat some buckwheat
noodles or buckwheat pancakes or
anything like that no okay but I did eat
gluten until I started on this program
good well you need to really get rid of
it your wife's got to get rid of it
everybody in your household you need to
warn your kids brothers and sisters all
that kind of stuff
and then
um
uh also I would throw in the synaptives
three of those twice a day so your brain
cells can talk to each other
okay you need three eggs twice a day
with soft yolk soft wild soft Pope sauce
scrambled butter hard boil don't count
Friday sauce cancer and so of course
supposedly prostate cancer so you need
to stay away from that
um
and you know give us a call every week
and give us a status report because your
scenario is very typical
okay the doctors are doing the basic
stuff that they've been taught
and they're going down to where the
symptom is as opposed to what's causing
the symptom Which is higher up
okay we need to rebuild the skull you
need to rebuild the brain uh you need to
rebuild the spinal cord
and um again I would get this book and
CD this will help you understand
everything it's on your head the book
and the CD and the actual recipe that I
just gave you is actually in here
okay so that you'll get the information
in writing and what a great Christmas
gift to give to everybody in your family
give them one of these if you get 10 of
any one book including this one you get
a big discount okay so why can't we have
lots of people buy 10 of these and they
give them to their family and friends
and so forth
um it's all in your head 37 different
diseases and uh you know here which I
say
typical of somebody who has obviously
approached to the skull and the doctors
are doing everything else scurrying
around deal with all the symptoms
locations and symptoms as opposed to
what's causing the symptoms which are
higher up the chain
so that big mass that I feel is from the
squeezing of the spinal cord that's
correct
yeah this goal has a big hole in the
back of it called frame and Magnum which
is Latin for B whole and you have
actually approach to the skull let me
show you something here you have how she
posted to the skull your skull gets
sicker a normal skull I'm a human being
is a quarter of an inch thick
and when you have offset process of the
skull
okay the top picture here is that we can
do this correctly there you go the top
picture is a normal skull quarter moon
six but down here in the lower part
okay here it's another human skull same
age
but it's it's actually
almost two inches thick it squeezing the
12 pairs of cranial nerves as they go
through the tunnels of squeezing the
spinal cord all the symptoms
I've done so many autopsies on people
that have this problem
okay and when you see that comparison to
two skulls which one would you rather
have you want the one on top
because one at the bottom is squeezing
those 12 pairs of cranial nerves
which
is that okay
I always get it wrong which is that okay
and all the things that those nerves do
well those tunnels that those nerves go
through give squeezed and that's what
all the problem is it's up here it's not
down in your lower back
okay yep
thank you Doc and that's why
this is true
only
Dead Doctors Don't Lie
the CDs in nine languages we've sold 900
million copies of the CDs in nine
languages
Dead Doctors Don't Lie it's the only
time they won't lie is when they're dead
okay there you go thank you
thank you David
and Dr Wallach I love the graphics that
are in that it's all in your head book
because I know so many of us are visual
Learners and whenever we can see
something and follow the paths and see
you know where that initial
you cannot argue
yeah argue with this scenario
oh you made that up no no I didn't make
that up those are real people okay it's
just really tragic but that's that's the
way it is
yeah that's just the thickening of the
skull and and folks see this white line
out here oh I can't see it yeah that's
the skull
oh okay can we dump this we have this
panel on the right hand side all I can
see is from your middle of your nose so
well ignore that panel Dr Wallach you
would have to minimize that panel and
dismiss it
um there you go again I've got a little
bit of it now
and then this here the thicker white
line yeah yeah there you go now you got
half of each of the skull it's going
right down through the middle of the
skulls yeah so it was what it was
originally considered pot Paget's
disease but then now yeah
yeah
autoimmune disease had this disease
right
well and and let's kind of look at this
see how thin the skull is up here in the
top
and then how thick it is here what's
going to happen whenever something
thickens
because if you look at it it's
thickening inside
and so those pain those tunnels the
nerves in the spinal cord goes through
get smaller the inside diameter gets
filled up by that connective tissue to
negative tissue and put the squeeze on
the spinal cord put the squeeze on those
12 pairs of cranial nerves and again
um when you get to uh let's see here
foreign
different diseases you get from
osteoposis installed it's all in the
book it's all in your head okay
now optic nerve atrophy loss of vision
ptosis the pupil cannot respond to light
double vision trigenal neuralgia pain in
the face terrible headaches uh double
vision uh Bell's palsy phase troops
tonight it's ringing in the ears
deafness vertigos dizziness belongs to
the gang reflects your voice changes it
moves it sends its face gastrocreases
terrible stomach pain they think you got
an ulcer chronic obstructive cornea
disease afib atrial fibrillation which
is not a heart disease but it does cause
irregular heart pieces to skull that
skull squeezing the tense cranial nerve
which controls the rate and Rhythm of
the heart okay lost the trapezius muscle
function atrophy of the tongue and
speech when you when you get atrophy of
um optic nerve excuse me of a cranial
number nine and twelve
that's what this guy's got that's why he
has all this stuff going on and the
doctors keep operating all over his
spine and that's not the problem
but he's got good
so doctors keep milking the dairy
herding
oh goodness well I love the fact that
um he has found us Dr Wallach and I have
heard how he's doing and the results
that he's getting so far he is just so
tickled over so thank you for coming on
yeah yeah well Dr Wallach let's go to
the next question now so this is a hair
analysis question Dr Wallach okay now
we've looked at quite a few hair
analysis and
one of the first charts it goes through
the nutritional elements
and lists many of the elements many of
the minerals that are found and Christy
had a hair analysis done
and on her chart it's showing that
calcium magnesium manganese Cobalt
lithium zirconium
phosphorus and selenium are all high
they're all in the upper part of the
chart now she has been on the product
she doesn't eat any of the bad foods
she's wanting to know what would cause
all of the readings to be really high
and she said that she started to lose
hair in mid-october she's 72
105 pounds
and five foot two
okay
well here launch has nothing to do with
age it's lack of nutrition getting to
the hair follicle or the hair is made
okay it also causes the lack of or the
loss of hair color that's not due to
aging it's due to nutrients of
efficiency okay
so
um when somebody has proper amounts of
the nutrients and minerals okay but yet
still has problems okay the problems
are not from lack of nutrients but for
the lack of of something else
a particular nutrient so that's what we
have a Chronicle Hair Skin and nails
okay
she needs to take fair skin and Nails
take three of those twice maybe two
bottles a month of hair skin nails keep
doing it here with healthy band and
heart attack uh give it all the bad
foods take the Hair Skin and Nails take
three of those twice a day
um because it's got all kinds of stuff
in there that actually help the hair
follicles and make more hair make more
hair color okay
and so
um she's got several things going on
there but obviously she's absorbing the
nutrients because they're showing up in
the in the hair analysis
okay
but
um there there's a communication problem
in the scalp level and so that's why I
go with the hair skin and Nails she
needs that collagen okay wouldn't hurt
if she's not she needed also to take the
um MSM to take the collagen peptides and
the Hair Skin and Nails I had that to a
program don't take anything away because
she's seen some good results there but
she needs to take these other things
including Hair Skin and nails
well Dr Wallach if she has great
absorption and she is a small person
with all of these
being high
would she be able to reduce her amounts
by maybe even a quarter
well let's see
how long it takes her to get the hair to
start growing back
okay so should she be concerned about
having high levels of all of these
valuable nutrients that our body needs
no she just needs to stay away from
wheat bun around oats and buckwheats and
you know all the fried foods and all the
bad stuff okay what she says she's doing
so good job on that Christy
um there just might be something that's
missing that's that the body is still
still wanting well you can have plenty
of nutrition but if you're missing
collagen
okay which is like
um
the
connective tissue
um from tendons and ligaments and
cartilage and that kind of stuff
maybe you know she's not getting that
you can be taking all the vitamins and
minerals in the world and not getting
collagen then you're having problems
with your with your hair follicles
that's like the the
um I mean Hair Skin and Nails okay
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach let's go to Deborah Deborah go
ahead and unmute yourself what question
do you have today for Dr Wallach
hi Dr Wallach my Becca team
um my question is thank you guys for
what you do I have several kind of
different questions different situations
I have somebody that has uh arthritis
issues and uh for a Cost Containment
she's gonna take the pig pack and she's
also been taking aspirin you know one a
day for you know a heart preventative
thing is that recommended that she can
continue with the aspirin or should she
stop the aspirin since she's going to be
on a pig pack
okay well I haven't changed that just a
little bit instead of the pig pack I
never take the pig arthritis formula
okay which is really our healthy
um Bone and Joint pack okay so the big
pack is the arthritis pack Dr Wallach
they just changed the name for honest
okay yeah the pig arthritis form no Pig
okay
and um so that that's going to uh we
actually our first collagen okay is our
glucajel which we made for our Theo
ratliffs a great basketball player okay
we help rebuild him uh he was 24 years
old and had bone bone arthritis in both
his knees it partly sipped off his hips
uh he fractured his wrist in a shooting
arm
um and the the Atlanta Hawks took away a
35 million dollar contract and it's 24
years of age we rebuilt him he came back
uh I don't know maybe uh three months
later got his position back and he
played for 11 more years made a hundred
million dollars now do you think Theo
likes our product
of course that's why his pictures on the
containers
okay
does she so it is it a problem for her
to continue on the aspirin
well aspirin uh is was an age-old
product for pain and swelling and that
kind of stuff but I would have her soul
to reduce it I wouldn't just hold turkey
off of it I would have her soul and
reduce it you know if she's been taking
one aspirin a day forever uh break it in
half and take a half and half an aspirin
per day for a couple of weeks and see if
that gives her the same results she's
looking for
okay but usually when you're taking all
this collagen and
um uh so forth it's going to reduce or
eliminate the discomfort and pain
all right of course we have the same
cream we have the
um
okay from our hemp effects division uh
and so forth we have all kinds of
topical and oral stuff for pain relief
that actually has nutrition in it
whereas aspirin doesn't get nutrition in
it but aspirin is you know like an
age-old thing that everybody uses you
know they self-diagnose arthritis or
joint pain or something like that and
they'll take aspirin they get pain
relief they'll get pain relief for a
couple years until
they're they can't walk anymore and then
they go in for a knee replacement let's
rebuild it before you need a knee
replacement okay yeah she said hers was
more preventative for heart issues oh
well that's for sure if she wants to
take something for prevention for heart
issues she can take the ultimate daily
classic tablets take three of those
times today all the daily classic tablet
system malnutrition whereas the aspirin
can actually slightly dilate the
arteries and the heart and the kidneys
so that you're getting a little bit more
blood flow okay uh also can blood
clots which can be life-threatening if
you you know if you get in a car
accident you've been on aspirin or you
bleed to death because you've been on
aspirin and so it's one of those things
were you know
it's a give and take here
all right thank you I have an another
question is uh an individual that has a
thyroid hypothyroidism and uh is the
doctor said because I know that they're
not supposed to eat uh cruciferous
vegetables but the doctor told her it's
okay to eat it as long as it's well
cooked
that doctor should have his or her
license taken away
okay
um basically when you have thyroid
issues
um they need the oceans gold take three
of those twice today for 100 pounds of
body weight stay away from all the bad
stuff
uh use our salt with all the minerals in
it okay the Himalayan salt are are
seasoned salt from Australia if the
Himalayan salt some back are
um and it has all these trace minerals
from the ocean
okay
um which does wonderful things for the
thyroid now that's why sea salt was the
first
um
nutritional supplements sold around the
world with sea salt because it not only
has sodium chloride not only has salt
but it also had the minerals from the
ocean and we could take people that had
enormously enlarged thyroid gland and
they were just really sick from thyroid
problems
okay and then in just two weeks on the
sea salt
with thyroid gland became normal
because the sour gland is very very
responsive to the supplements okay okay
one other question is there a form of
synaptic that comes in powder or a
liquid or a substitute
well we do have
these synaptives that comes in that
cream it's put on
the joint
that's the one I like to use if I you
know hurt myself working in the yard or
building a truck or something like that
Dr Wallach is only in about only in a
tablet
um
no she's asking about synaptics
okay and so Deborah one thing that you
can do is you can grind that up into a
powder and mix it with other like the
Tangy Tangerine okay okay all right
thank you so much just keep in touch
with us because you have some great
questions here thank you thank you Dr
wallet
all right thank you Deborah
um next Ruth Ellen has had her hand up
and unfortunately as a co-host her hand
is not up in the order that it was
received it's been up for a long time so
Ruth Ellen if you could please unmute
yourself you're on live with Dr Wallach
did you have a question for Dr Alex I do
have a question that is from one of my
clients
um his name is Albert and he is
63 years old he weighs 220 pounds and
he's five foot ten
he is not on a gluten-free diet and
we're working on that
um but he had a question and I wanted to
make sure that it got to you so he since
he was 16 years old he's had tinnitus
notice that he noticed it started when
he had drainage from the sinus area one
time
and then when it drained his ears
started to ring
um having that noise and also right
before that he had his wisdom teeth out
so we wanted to know if there was any
correlation to that and then he has
graying and silvering hair
and I know he's 60.
3 63 years ago
but when did all this stuff start when
he was a teenager 16 years old 16 yeah
okay now the fact that he had his wisdom
teeth taken out and he had tonight is
ring in the ears that's osteoporosis of
the skull because when your wisdom teeth
are loose so they're floating around
moving around receding gums and
everything guess what your jaw is part
of
still it's part of the skull thing so
when you actually approach to the skull
you're going to get osteoposis of the
jaw as the jaw shrinks the teeth get
loose and that's why they pull the
wisdom teeth out
okay so he and how she approaches this
girl babies are born
okay
um with osteoporosis is called so it's
not something that only occurs in older
people
proficiency it's not an agent right
right okay no yes and 120 pounds and you
give it all the bad foods uh two how the
Grain and heart attacks a month the
photo sending twice a day uh two bottles
a month to the MSM so you take three of
breakfast you're going through dinner he
needs a collagen peptides to those
cancers mustn't take a scoop with
breakfast scoop with a dinner drinks he
needs the Beyond
ask you a Vex you need more calcium
Beyond Azure effects take a scuba that
twice a day in the drinks I do that
every morning and then
he also needs the vitamin D three three
of those twice a day he needs a
synaptives three of those twice a day
two dollars a month he also needs uh
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
soft soft scrambled in butter or soft uh
post soft boiled hard-boiled eggs won't
count and Fridays cause cancer
so those are the sort of things that
will help him solve those problems it's
going to take a little while because
he's he said how she approaches the
skull since he was 16. okay so this is
going to be fixed overnight this might
take two three months but he'll see some
benefit very quickly
okay and then he had two more questions
um he is
um anastatin medication and so he needs
to hear it from a doctor not me should
he continue discontinue his Statin
medication
and also he has borderline high blood
pressure medication to prevent blood
clots
it's cholesterol
use cholesterol yeah so the doctor put
him on a Statin medication for
cholesterol and then he's on a
medication for blood pressure he usually
cut it by 30 and then a month cut by
half and then after the third month drop
it
beating those three eggs twice a day
um cholesterol is one of your best
friends and so for doctors to put them
on drugs at lower cholesterol and tell
them to change his back to avoid
cholesterol is actually uh should be
malpractice
I agree I agree okay
and he takes less a low sartin 50
milligrams twice a day for his blood
pressure but his blood pressure numbers
are not that high they're just a little
bit higher than what they consider
normal
okay well we need the older daily
classic tablets through those twice
today uh two bottles a month and if he's
on the the low Statin in these other
blood pressure medications don't pull
turkey off of them but as the blood
pressure begins to drop they can still
reduce the medication based on the
numbers might take 30 60 90 days and
he'll be often blood pressure medication
because
um if he's only a few points above
normal it'll be very quickly he'll
respond positively okay
thank you so much well thank you very
welcome
all right thank you Ruth Ellen and
Doctor well like
let's go to Lori who has her hand up
Lori go ahead and unmute yourself
hello
um my son is relatively new to
youngevity and he uh asked me to join in
and so
um I think my story is pretty simple 33
years ago I was diagnosed with Graves
disease and I before I did take the
radioactive iodine pill
to uh I guess kill part of it I felt
horrible I never slept I shook I had all
the all the symptoms bugging eyes and
all that but anyway I felt like I did
what they told me the doctors uh and
felt pretty good throughout this
question let me ask you a question
why do you trust doctor so much
well at the time
they told me I could have died because I
if I had a thyroid storm I was so the
tests were I was so overactive but I I
felt a million times better but anyway
that's all in the past I had it where I
was feeling like a million bucks but
then
uh about a week ago I I think stress
triggers uh when I have hyperthyroid I'm
not a hypo so there's a difference but
anyway my question is
because the doctor said when they did
these blood tests normally they would
just check it to make sure I had the
right level of well it's the generic for
Synthroid which is
levothyroxine I think is how you
pronounce it
right right I take uh let's see I've got
my bottle right here I think I take
112 mcgs of that every day and I I feel
like if I stopped I would be a shaky
mess but anyway that was why I went in
there to say oh maybe it's off why am I
feeling fatigued and what happened was
there were three things that came up he
wanted to do a protein uh more blood
analysis so here's my question my
immobile globin G qn Serum is high it's
there it says
it's
2128 when it should be between
500 and 1600 or something like that what
do you suggest
that why it's high in my blood analysis
for that
it's hard to say but here's the deal
um you need to get our oceans gold
why should they Ocean's gold
Ocean's gold
they treat my today stay away from all
the bad stuff no fried foods
okay and then
um
Watch What Happens your thyroid is going
to be very happy engraved at ease goes
away very quickly
okay don't cold turkey off your
medication but as your symptoms get
better you can slowly reduce it and
um uh you know you're looking for a
great result within 30 to 60 days and
within 60 90 days you should be a
totally new person okay now how long do
you have to stay on all these nutrients
you know they're being hard pack and the
MSM and the collagen peptides and okay
and the ocean's gold well how long do
you need oxygen
the thing is you know it's easy to say
just don't take it but one time I went
on vacation and didn't have it
and
my body fell tell me what it is you see
I didn't have it what is it the medicine
centroid or generic Center I'm not
saying cold turkey off of it I'm saying
after you've been on our program
for a month well then I guess I'd go to
the doctor he'd test me because I can't
just take lower amount I'd have to be
it'd have to be prescribed you can't
just I don't know
um how that can happen you know it's not
like you can take a half a pill or I
mean they would have to give me the
lower dosage
well you can crack pills in half with a
butter knife
we absolutely recommend that you work
with your primary care physician and
making sure that you are getting your
prescriptions because they were
prescribed by a primary care physician
we do have to recommend that you work
with your primary care physician to have
that lowered but remember you're the
authority of your own health so if
you're feeling better
take it upon yourself to go see your
doctor and say hey I don't think I need
this anymore
or hold on just a minute
you got muted Lori
okay
well they they were telling me I need to
see a hematologist because
not only the hemoglobin was high the
free Kappa LT chain was high do you know
anything about that there were three
areas of my blood that were high
I'm very familiar with that and I
recommend if you have not started our
program yet please start our program
give us 90 days get tested get our
program
does that mean because the person the
products the duck that Dr Wallach is
recommending for you that you can get
with your son and he can help you get
them ordered in the mail to you you're
talking about the ocean's gold or which
other products 90 essential nutrients
which is the brain and heart pack
well I have been on for maybe two years
what they call I don't know if you've
ever seen this one athletic greens and
yeah it's not the same it's not the same
well it's very similar if you read
according to my son who's told me to
come on here that some things that are
not on it and what's amazing with that
product and that product is not
including the cofactors that the body
needs to actually use the nutrients that
are in that product and not all of them
are in a form that the body can actually
use and that's one thing that I love
about our products I've been on that
product it did nothing for me oh really
I felt results when I got on Dr Wallach
protocol
and that's why I'm here today
so I have gone from having
I can't remember his 13 or 17 different
dose diagnoses and 13 and 17 different
Pharmaceuticals and now I'm not on any
of them or have any of those diagnoses
so one of them thyroid one of them had
to do with thyroid absolutely so give us
the brain and heart pack Ocean's gold is
one of the secret sauces that are
specifically designed to help support
support thyroid function so is the Z
radical
but
Dr Wallach did you finish the full
protocol for Lori
um I I think that's a good start you
know you know the 90 plus MSM plus
looking at the book and which like which
one is it that I would order what's it
called so it's called the healthy body
brain and heart pack 2.0 or 2.5
Ultra so if you could if you could have
your son or reach out to us at Doc at
drjwalik.com we'll make sure that we get
the protocol to you okay okay several
hands and only a few minutes left so I
want to try to make sure that we we get
everybody you're important too
but go ahead and use that doc at
drjwallik.com and we'll get that
answered for you okay great thank you
thank you Lori
all right doc let's go to the next town
that is up and Shantae actually before
we get to you Shantae I'm sorry we had a
question at the beginning and she got
booted and her hand got out of order
here and Liz has a question
in regards to
um
she's 57.
140 pounds
five foot seven tall
she does have a diagnosis of
osteoporosis L thank you Liz for coming
up on here with us
um she also has a calcium Stone that's
not cause any any problems
um but her urine test and the urine pH
is high she's cautious about taking
vitamin C
um which she knows that it's needed for
the osteoporosis but the question is
won't it cause the kidney stone to be
worse
vitamin C will not cause a kidney stone
to be worse oh you have to appreciate
when you have a kidney stone you have
raging osteoporosis
okay you have raising osteoporosis and
at 140 pounds she needs two healthy
brain and heart patch a month get rid of
all the bad foods good food bad food
lists get rid of bad foods she needs two
healthy brand heart pasture months two
bottles a month of the MSM should take
three breakfast treat lunch or dinner
time two cancers of the collagen
peptides can take a scoop of breakfast
food with dinner time she needs the
Beyond osteoflex as you can take ones
who have breakfast lunch to a dinner
time vitamin D three three of those 20s
a day and
um
the osteoporosis can be fatal I mean
friend you know get a fracture
obstacrosis a skull can cause you to
black out where you're driving or
something like that now you don't just
get osteoporosis of your right knee when
you get out of your process it's in
every bone and every joint in your body
including your skull
and so there's a lot going on here so
she needs to jump on this some
nutritional regimen ASAP
thank you thank you Doctor you bet all
right thank you Liz glad I was able to
get to that
oh
and now let's go to the next hand that
is up and Shantae
thank you Shantae go ahead and unmute
yourself
it's saying you're not allowing me am I
am I on there I hear you loud and clear
okay okay all right my question is about
because the osteoporosis of the skull
and the need for more calcium
what if the calcium products are causing
bowel issues
how do you get enough calcium because I
know we don't have calcium we don't use
calcium without magnesium or if you do
you're not accomplishing much because of
the absorption Factor the ratio has to
be right right Dr wallet
so the question is how do you go about
doing that and
deal with the bowel issues
well make sure that there's no gluten in
your life everybody not there we
associate with you and putting the dog
in the cat going to be gluten-free
contamination okay and then
um we don't just have a calcium product
we don't just have a calcium magnesium
product right um when you look at our
products we have 75 minerals
right okay so we're a totally different
animal so this is
um a a balance of minerals from the seed
okay all the sea life including plants
and algae and
um those kinds of things
um the uh all the sea animals use it and
we have some you know Wonderful products
with them nobody has a program like we
have to get all the minerals in the
right balance with each other into you
okay and so you know if your concerned
start low
um if if you need because of your body
weight you need to take
um two ounces a day uh start out with a
half ounce to breakfast
okay well it is the Osteo FX I finally
switched to
um the bio calcium to see if that would
be
um you know a because of the different
ratios if that would help any but still
it seems like anytime there's calcium
that within the youngevity line because
it also is going to include magnesium is
causing bowel issues so that's was my
main question as to how do you get
enough calcium because there's symptoms
in the body I cannot answer that
question from 3000 miles away and O'Hare
and Allison says in front of me okay
okay the hair analysis all right one
other question if you don't mind
addressing real quickly uh lupus
okay lupus is a combination of irritable
bowel syndrome which is a gluten issue
uh skin issues which is a nutritional
deficiency of collagen and uh oftentimes
a rash in the face and upper body
usually when the people have the rash on
the face the upper body they're eating
buckwheat and pancakes noodles that kind
of stuff
um
because buckwheat that's one of the side
effects of Buckwheat is to get the
rashes on your face and your upper body
and so forth
but irritable bowel syndrome is a big
part of Lupus okay and doctors want you
to believe it's in our immune disease no
it's simply a gluten issue and
nutritional deficiencies and you can
wind up with having pressure and
diabetes and joint problems and
arthritis and all this kind of stuff
that goes along with all these
deficiencies because when you have
irritable bowel syndrome remember that
picture of the Villi there will I go
away instead of being like a shag rug
they turn into just being two big knots
in your intestine and you cannot absorb
efficiently and so even if you're taking
it it's gone out the other end
okay and that's what causes lupus and of
course they just want to give you
Cortisone and that kind of stuff and and
so on anti-inflammatories
because they falsely believe that it
says our immune disease they said that
100 years ago because they didn't have
any answers
and so they're still teaching 100 year
old misinformation in medical schools
all right well thank you yeah so you get
the hair analysis and if all your
minerals are low guess what
you're not observing
so if we're not if we're not absorbing
then that would be the digestive pack so
we need more flora and more enzymes no
you need to get away from gluten there's
no gluten that's not an issue we've not
been on gluten for probably
three years okay good and that includes
buckwheat you can't have any break no
I've never been a book in fact I just
threw my buckwheat away because I've had
it for several years in the freezer and
never used it and I'm like this is
stupid so I just threw it away okay but
anyway I had it there because I thought
it was healthy version and I could it
could be a gluten-free version but the
more you've talked about it recently I'm
like well there's no need of even trying
to figure that out and just threw it
away but no it's not been anything that
we've had in our diet at all okay good
okay so
the absorption I guess we'll just have
to keep working on the absorption even
with the microbiome though
um it's still by our ultimate enzymes so
our ultimate enzymes and you get older
enzymes okay
they told those say 10 minutes before
you can go a couple ounces of water see
if that helps
okay so we'll do our best yep thank you
they can't produce enough enzymes
yeah
all right thank you so much Shantae
um and let's go to the next town that is
up Dr Wallach and Wayne go ahead and
unmute yourself
hi good morning Dr walek and the crew
yes doctor I've found that in recent
times when using my phone holding it to
my ears after a short time my left hand
gets a cramp
I get a cramp in my Palms my finger
fingers
okay you ever have any ring in your ears
we were driving no I don't have ring in
my ears okay if you ever had any
headaches
no but as I told a few weeks ago I had
when I turned my head like that I do
sometime here um like click of sounds
in my neck
okay how many times you wake up at night
to urinate once three times five times
sometime once sometime more than once
well can we say more than once twice
three times five times say twice okay
yeah I think it might actually
approaches to the skull squeezing
some of the 12 pairs of cranial nerves
in your spinal cord
because we wake up at night to urinate
that means your spinal cord is being
squeezed and it's telling your
urinary bladder to urinate
and that's why you have a nice urinate
because the skull is having that effect
through the
um spinal cord being squeezed coming out
of the skull
okay
and that would explain your headaches
and that kind of stuff
no no I don't have a headachea
so I I would like to talk a little bit
about thank you Wayne for your question
and I think that does
the osteoporosis of the skull and this
is this is why
so as you're holding this like this
the neck is not completely lined up so
it's causing some pressure here at the
atlas where the vagus nerves are coming
out and through
and then causing tingling numbness pain
in the hand so it's a referred pain it's
not so much that there's a problem here
it's up here with the way that you're
holding and that's Falls in line with
the frequency of having to get up and
urinate especially if you're a side
sleeper and you move or rotate you're
going to get some extra pinching as the
spine is moving back and forth and
causing that
referred
it wouldn't be a pain but that referred
sensation then that you need to have to
go to the restroom for those that have
frequencies and I know that you
mentioned you know waking up once or so
during the night
um
doesn't isn't alarming for the most part
especially if you have 16 ounces of
water before you go to bed so but Dr
wellick
um we have a few minutes if you could
explain what is happening when that
skull is sickening I'd greatly
appreciate that Wayne did you have
something else that you wanted to add
real quick the issue I raised a while
ago is not just if I have the food on my
ears if I have the if I'm just typing
let's say I'm doing a text and have the
food in my hand before me and I'm typing
or if I'm even on um how are you how are
you holding it
so that you're
so then just before me and I'm typing
Arduino text
not necessarily leading my head but if I
have it before me and type in I do
sometimes have the cramps in my fingers
okay now let me let me answer that
question
have you ever heard of Bell's Palsy on
one side of the face troops
yes in fact I know somebody with that
right now okay good now maybe a couple
months later the other side will droop
okay maybe it'll never droop on the
other side well the same thing is
happening with you you're getting
symptoms on one side okay because
nothing in nature
is identical okay and so you can have
osteoporosis of the skull and it's worse
on one side than it is on the other side
and that's why you haven't come that's
what why you have things like Bell's
Palsy on one side so often as opposed to
both sides
okay
and it's it's um uh the same thing is
true for numbness tingling on hands and
so forth okay okay same principle all
right thank you we need to rebuild that
skull open up those tunnels so the
nerves can get through there without
being squeezed okay that's that's our
whole goal here all right thank you you
bet can keep in touch and talk to us
every week
certainly will thank you
all right thank you Wayne thank you Dr
Wallach and so we're gonna have to talk
about what happens during osteoporosis
of the skull you know what what the
physio physiological effects are
sometime but we're at the end of our
show
so if I could get my co-host to come up
here with me that would be absolutely
fabulous and say hello
I'm not how come I'm not seeing
everybody
where'd they go there we go
thank you so much
um so everybody on behalf of the ass doc
Live Crew Dr Judy Reynolds John T
mccollier nasima Omar Ruth Ellen Sanchez
and of course the doc that we're asking
live Dr Joel Wallach we thank you so
much for joining us get back with the
person that shared this program with you
and thank them for the information that
you heard because it is empowering folks
there's so many things and I know you
heard Dr Wallach mention osteoporosis of
the skull almost every single situation
well that is because
those nutrition nutritional deficiencies
are causing so many different conditions
so we need to address the body as a
whole we need to make sure that we're
keeping the bones strong we want to make
sure that the digestive system is in its
optimal best so that you can get the
best results from the investment that
you make into yourself
with intentional supplementation in a
form that the body can actually use and
absorb because
it he
there aren't any missing components here
folks Dr wallach's research and formulas
have been proven time and time again
that if you're having issues with them
it's because we need to work on the
digestive system so that you can best
absorb and utilize within the body so Dr
Wallach thank you so much again for
joining us for these two hours thank you
to my co-hosts for all of the
information that they put into the chat
if you're on live with us and you had a
question that we did not get to please
go to askdoclive.com click contact us
send us an email and myself or one of my
certified holistic health coaches will
get back with you and get your questions
answered so you also can feel the
difference again my name is Becca Deeks
Kozak and
on behalf of the askdoc life crew bye
for now
bye-bye love you guys love you gals love
you doc love you dear bye-bye